Thank You miss wasco
We have
Brian coming up
Okay, item number two joint study session truck intensive use ordinance land use study and North pyrite master plan
Mr. Pesch's
Maybe have a staff report on this item, please. I
Do thank you Madam Mayor members of the City Council and Planning Commission
Tonight we're going to go over the truck intensive ordinance and the associated projects
So let me start off as PowerPoint
so
Early on we were experiencing a lot of concerns in the city of Haroopa Valley with truck traffic issues
the city codes were
not in in
Sync with what our desires were in terms of the control of a truck traffic in the community. We've concerned with the impacts
on truck traffic to our residents and
the community as a whole and this led to on January 21st the city adopting a moratorium on truck intensive uses and we also and
and
Then on February 18th went to the City Council and we extended that moratorium to allow more time for staff to develop
standards and solutions to these problems
One of the first things is staff did and working on this project was to come up with a definition really for study purposes to
You know truly define what truck and cancer uses are
and the main point of this I won't read the whole thing for you, but it's really just to address these
types of projects industrial projects to create significant amounts of truck traffic and
the adverse impacts that they have to our residential neighborhoods such as blight and
infrastructure deterioration
pollution traffic congestion
pedestrian safety and such and
And what it does is it really reduces our livability of our community
Lores property values and the grades community without generating any revenue for the community the city
Or any significant jobs for our residents
So tonight I'm going to hit on three components of what we're
proposing as the solution to this problem
The first is a draft truck intensive ordinance that will identify where truck intensive uses ought to go and
also
Some solutions in terms of revised permit uses and allowable uses in different zones
We'll also be providing land use for recommendations for our different industrial zones and potential changes for the city council and planning commission to consider
And finally we're going to be discussing the concept of a development for the north pyrite master plan
So part one the truck intensive uses
ordinance so
First of all with what this ordinance doesn't touch is the distribution warehouse use which is currently regulated through the
general plan and the zoning code and requires them to be in an overlay with approval of the city council and
That process seems to be working well and so I'm basically that wasn't part of the scope
and
What we did do is we established heavy
Manifest our manufacturing heavy is the only zone in the city that will allow these truck intensive uses with the conditional use permit and
In hand with that we will be removing truck intensive uses from the other
industrial zones of manufacturing zones in the community
And this will in terms address some of the problems we've had with scattered small parcels of industrial development throughout
the community
So this map here in the purple shows the current
MH zoning where the truck intensive uses would be allowed the primary areas are really the
Loma Linda area and the Agua Monza area in the kind of upper left and right hand
areas of the city
There's a small amount along the very southern edge of the community down by the Santa River as well
so
In addition to prohibiting the uses of truck intensive uses in these
industrial zones except for the MH
We also specifically called out two uses to prohibit them from the city altogether
The first is the vehicle storage yards, which would be prohibited with two exceptions when when they're ancillary to a primary use
And also when they're entirely enclosed with a bill within a building
the second
Land use that we're considering or proposing for a removal as an allowable use in the city this truck stops and travel centers and
Although these uses aren't specifically called out in the zoning code
there are
components of these uses
Or of a truck stop are so gasoline stations, convenience stores truck repair
car wash etc are all out in these zones, so we
Prated a definition for truck stops and travel centers and we also prohibit them and in the
Industrial as well as our commercial zones in the community or wherever gas stations and service stations are allowed
so another thing it's important to point out because there are some properties what you know certainly would be affected with this amendment and
if
They're legally established uses prior to the amendment going to the effect they wouldn't need to be removed from the
Zone that they're in
They would be allowed to become legal non-conforming and remain as long as 40 years from the effective date of the amendment
They'd also be allowed to expand up to 25% of their total area at the time the amendment went into place
so as we were studying this issue one of the things that we noticed was that there were a number of projects that were
Truck related, but they really didn't meet that definition that we established in the beginning with a type of use
It they generated a significant amount of truck traffic
These were smaller projects that were really kind of more mom and pop or family-owned businesses that you know had trucks
Related to the business themselves, but again, they weren't creating impacts to the community. So we wanted to
Cast a more refined net on what you know is captured under truck intensive and
Allow for these kinds of uses to remain under certain circumstances
so one of the things we had to try and figure out was well, you know, if we wanted to allow these what would be the threshold to
keep them under so they don't become a problem to the community and
and
Actually create a situation where we don't actually solve the problem. We're trying to solve through this process and
one of the things that came to mind was that
grocery stores are all over our community
Typically close to sensitive uses like residential sometimes schools
and other such uses, but they don't seem to really create
Traffic truck traffic impacts. I mean they might have other issues, but but definitely they're not something that would be
a big concern. So we decided to look at that as maybe a way to think about what would be the truck generation rate that
that would be a low impact for a community and
We were lucky enough to find a very extensive study that was done up in Washington State, which
surveyed hundreds of stores and
Anyway, the result of the survey was the average truck trips a day for a grocery stores around 18
So we use that as part of our kind of foundation and deciding what to do
we also looked at a
number of examples that were kind of in the holding pattern of
projects in the city and the first example here, excuse me, is a fence company. It's a family-owned business
they've been in Riverside and Riverside area for over 40 years and
They want to develop a property in a group of Valley for a 10,000 square foot building on a 1 acre lot
They generate they only have two trucks. They generate four trips a day
Leaving incoming each day. So this seemed to be
very much below the standard that we're looking at and
Then another example a little bit more complex project
This project is a post cold storage and associated truly a mixed-use project where off
Bill grave Avenue the access to the cold storage would be and then in the front half off mission is basically a
commercial center with outdoor
Vegetable stands and a meat market and different kind of grocery type of uses
So this particular case the cold storage is
20,000 square feet approximately and generates 12 truck trips a day
So anyway after looking at these and a number of other projects we came up with a standard threshold and
The threshold is a site. It's no larger than one acre a
Building area that humans have her individuals and over 30,000 square feet and
That they'd be at least 30 earth service. Sorry. Sorry at least 500 feet from a residential or sensitive use such as a school or church and
This would be applied to the
Industrial zones in the city
It would require
It would require a conditional use permit
And it would also require special development standards that are rule-based
In addition standard conditions of approval that require that once they're approved that they demonstrate continual operational
compliance
If there were any issues then the city could go back and change the conditions or potentially revoke the permit altogether
So just to give you some idea of some of the standards we're talking about we have
Basically screening of all the kind of more unsightly areas of the operation of a these kinds of facilities might have such as outdoor storage areas
Loading and service areas trash enclosures and such
Also, it would require perimeter screen rolls to be located along the front yard and street sides
line or street side property lines
Then the perimeter walls be fully landscaped in front of them and that they'd be at least eight feet in height
They have graffiti protection
Standards would also include paving of all parking lot areas and storage areas
and also that there be a
requirement for
ongoing maintenance and the properties be maintained in a clean and orderly fashion
so that includes the
summary of the proposed ordinance and
part two is a
Basically a discussion on the land use studies. So there's five different options that we're looking at our study areas
We're looking out here built
Bill town a glomonza
Bill grave and beer in the airport area
Hadley limonite and the north pyrite master plan and then one bonus area which is the
Area in northern part of the city Sierra Avenue on the and we'll talk about that as well
So here's the five study areas in the area a little in yellow and then the little area in purple is the Sierra
Study or area that we're also suggesting some land use change
So how we went about this is we went through an extensive inventory every study area we did a
Existing land use survey of the entire area as well as looking at approved
projects or projects under construction as well, and this is an example of what we did in Belltown and
Algomonza
so the other thing we looked at is we looked at the existing zoning and
You know keep in mind that the zoning really follows the land use patterns that were approved by the County of Riverside
And we more or less inherited so they don't necessarily always reflect kind of our community goals
So the other
tool that we had of course was the general plan and in this case
you can see that
That the general plan and the zoning map don't always in exactly at line
So we looked at both maps and also the existing land uses and the character of each area
so for the
Algomonza area this recommendation is what one thing we didn't notice as we looked at this is a long 20-inch street
There was a clear divided line. I go back
You can even see it with the land use there's that dividing line right here between the purple and the yellow
where you have
Really you kind of have three areas in Algomonza you have this kind of lighter industrial area up here
You have all the heavy industrial and and kind of on the outskirts of the area you have some residential and commercial mixed in
So the goal here again was to really keep any more industrial from creeping down below 28th Street and really
Focus that area on the commercial residential and business part that's over to you there and in
enhanced those uses and then really take an opportunity here to create something special along rubo rubido boulevard
Because currently there's a lot of vacant land there and we saw the the chance or opportunity to to improve the area
So what we're recommending is we create a rubido a business park corridor
Especially beyond 28th Street
From the 28th Street down south to the interchange we would be looking at more of a commercial corridor
And that would include a number of street improvements and this is just kind of to give you a fashion of the idea
I'm the Tupper the upper photograph there shows, you know landscape areas along the street with setbacks off the street and
a street medium and so certain landscape improvements to go along with it and
And then also this would dovetail with a future planning effort through some of the development agreements
There's been a funny mechanism that's been created for a rubido specific plan
So these concepts would be beginning concepts that we could again build up build upon with the specific plan as it moves forward
So the other are the next area I'd like to talk about is Bill grave and beer in
And here again is the existing zoning as you can see most of the study area is currently
MSC in terms of its zoning
And then when we look at the general plan we see the pink area there
Really replacing a lot of that
MSC to business park in the the purple area is
industrial zoning or light industrial zoning
Or land use I should say
So one of the things that really noticed was and there's a need up here on the north part of and Buren
Right there that
There's a lot of
Properties that are in bad condition and could use some cleanup and improvement and so
we're
recommending that that be converted over to business park as
Consistent with the general plan as well as the rest of the area
And then with the business park
Next one next slide
We're suggesting that we update our business park standards as well
Our business park standards are pretty much copies of our other industrial zones
And it don't really reflect what a modern business park would look like or how the general plan actually describes our business parks as
You know research and development and job opportunity zones
so the first thing we would do is
amend this section or this this code section to
Take
Currently there's uses in the zone that are allowed by rights
So we would eliminate all allowed by right uses and require site development permits
This would be consistent with all the other industrial zones in the city in
addition
We would update the allowed uses to be you know kind of fit more modern types of business parks
We see in other communities in the inland empire and in addition
We would evaluate each land use and ensure that they general they match the general plan intent for business parks
And we would also require some of the uses that are maybe more intensive to
receive conditional use permits
So the the next zone I'd like to talk about is the flabob airport area or study area
And in this particular area we have two recommendations the first is the short-term recommendation
to go forward with this initiation process
which is to change some of the
the heavy or the
MH zone or the
manufacturing heavy to the
MSC so you can see that gray area there whoops
But it was pressing the pointer there you go. Sorry. So the gray area the dark gray area would be changed over to
MSC and then an area just right above it right here is
going to be changed to business park using consistent with the general plan and
Then the second recommendation would to be would be to move forward with it either an airport specific plan
or a special zoning for the airport and
If you look at the general plan, it actually designates the areas airport
So that would be consistent with what the general plan proposes
And then the the last study area is pedaling limonite
and again this particular area is
Mostly MSC and MH
And one of the areas that we were particularly wanted to try and address is
Right in here. There's a lot of issues with
Some of the properties here and a lot of non-conforming uses and code enforcement cases
So we really look for some cleanup on that particular area and
If you look at the general plan, you see that you know that area is being changed to business park
So we would support that
idea
And then to be more specific some of the things that we're looking at is the business park change again
to help clean up that area and
Then also along Clay Street right here right here
We like to change the zoning just to be consistent with it. What's there?
Up at the upper half of Clay Street is a
medical building and then a senior facility
So we'd like to just make sure that whatever the zone change there as consistent with those land uses and
Then in the center part there. There's a proposal for residential. So we'll just let that play out and
Whatever the City Council and Planning Commission decide on those particular
Properties will follow seat on the zoning and then the final lower area would be commercial
There's also a small area over here. That's business park that would be it's currently commercial that we would change to business park
and then the final area is
That area that I mentioned it wasn't originally part of the study areas Sierra Avenue in the northern border area
this particular area is
Once a quarry and now I believe
Sorry
the Oak quarry golf course and
Back in the day when it was a quarry the County
allowed the area in purple to be used as a staging area for the quarry and it was also thought that at some point that the
Mining would expand to the other side of Sierra Avenue and so that was zoned
MH by the County
well that never occurred and
Further if you look at the the photograph down below the existing land used the into the area is entirely vacant and it's a very
steep terrain and it really doesn't make a lot of sense to continue with the image zoning there and
also consistent with the general plan that particular zone is
basically W1 which is a water course watershed or basically an open space conservation area and then there's a proposal right now for a
Residential use right along Sierra Avenue. So again, we would let that play out
Depending on what the decision is by the Planning Commission and City Council for that particular application
but it likely the general plan has it as residential and a one so
If it weren't to proceed then we would just go with the a1 zoning
So that it concludes part two of this presentation and now we're moving on to the North Pyrite master plan
Let's take a brief drink of water
So one of the things that you know the first thing you know, we need to
examine in this particular area is the existing land uses
So as you can see there's a couple of existing
auto-related uses with the pick apart and the auto
auction or insurance auto auction site and then the I guess almost notorious string field string fellow acid pits
which is now, you know a recommendation site and
The in the center here is the quarry and the riverside mining operations
I like this aerial photo because it really kind of shows
How as the quarry moves north and creates this flat space which has, you know, some opportunity at some point in time later
down the road when the the mining operations cease to exist and
then the other aspect of this is
The kind of frontage area which is primarily vacant and probably the has the greatest opportunity of any of the areas because it's not as encumbered with some of the other
Issues with string fellow and the mining operation and the existing uses
So we look at the general plan land use for this particular area and I have the
Pyrite master plan area highlighted or
designated in the dotted lines and you can see that the current zoning for the
area that we're looking or land use from the general plan for the area that we're looking at is heavy industrial and
commercial tourists along the
Freeway
So this was basically the general theme that the master plan follows and in fact the uses proposed
Do not require a general plan amendment in order to implement and then I just wanted to show you a quick look at the existing
uses in the zoning code and
Those would be again be updated in order to be consistent with the general plan and I shouldn't mention over here. Well, let me
Not jump ahead. It was good at the next slide
The master plan itself is not a zoning document or a specific plan
It's a policy document but a policy document that would include a clear vision for the area
land uses that are permitted
development standards a circulation plan a phasing plan and design criteria and the
Master plan and visions basically two planning areas the one next to the Freeway being called the image zone in the area within the canyon the industrial park zone
so
Starting with planning area one or a which is the vision zone
What we're looking at is, you know, basically an image zone along the Grand Hill Drive and the Freeway
and
We're looking for new development. The characterizes basically a really high aesthetic architecture for professional
businesses and offices lodging dining entertainment and
The intent of the zone is really to create a job center for prep professional
and management for higher paying jobs and employment for the community taking advantage of a high volume exposure of the Freeway
and the pyrite Freeway interchange and
also creating
diversity of commercial and economic uses in the community that currently aren't represented here and
then finally we want to make a statement that the city is a prestigious address and
Place its worth investing in
so again as I mentioned the image zone here is outlined in yellow in that aerial and the
current zoning or the proposed zoning is going to be CT and
Again, it would be the shops restaurants hotels and things that basically attract
Freeway type business
And then also I should note that we have a parallel
Project going on on the property basically
Poppy just right along here
is
in the process through a
Isn't the process of reason to the CT or
Commercial tourist as part of the general plan consists the implementation program. So that's moving forward
even without this effort and then
Planning area B
Which is the industrial park zone which would be located, you know further behind the the image zone?
Which is somewhat protected topographically from views from the public?
The vision there would be to have a cluster of industrial buildings
For skilled labor and professional employment buildings varying in size from 50 to 150,000 square feet
to accommodate manufacturing fabrication and assembly
Architecture again to be you know nice quality with landscaping and having kind of a campus park like setting
as part of it and then the kind of the photos up above show kind of the
You know what we're talking about in terms of the building sizes and what we're trying to create and then
Finally we would should mention that this would also accommodate distribution warehouses
Part of that allowable use there
But again that would be the one aspect of this project that would require a general plan amendment in order to allow the overlay in this zone
And then just to give you an idea the industrial zone would allow uses that are currently allowed in our industrial
areas in the community and
One example is the Empire Business Center in which is in
Mira Loma
Says kind of the character what we're trying to create there
so
In addition to
What we're trying to allow?
There would be certain prohibited uses here and these more or less just
mirror what we're doing and the
truck intensive use overlay and
I mean truck intensive use ordinance and basically we would
Eliminate industrial uses with 20% or more the site
Having outdoor storage
Truck stops and travel centers again would be eliminated storage yards for trucks again would be eliminated
Commercial industrial storage yards as a principal use would not be allowed heavy equipment rentals
Retail sales auction and solid yards again
This basically is the same thing we're doing with the zoning amendment and then the design guidelines
This is just a more visual
Picture of what we're looking at in terms of the kinds of quality
This ring ring down below shows kind of both uses
This is more of a commercial section here and here's the more of the industry on the back
Kind of give an example with a higher quality architecture up front and then still a nice architecture in the back
With lots of landscaping in a park like setting
So
As we've been going through this process, I like to talk now about you know some of the things that we've
Heard from the community. We had a stakeholder meeting on September 23rd and
Some of the feedback we got was from Mariloma residents concerned with cumulative
impacts to their area with truck uses and air quality and
They had concerns with even a limited truck use
uses being allowed in a distance requirement of
500 feet they thought it should be at least a thousand
Also, there was some mention about the transition of electric vehicles in the future
And how that should help reduce some of the impacts particularly air quality impacts to the community
There was a clarification by staff about the
distribution warehouse regulations remaining the same and also clarification that I mentioned earlier about the legal non-conforming uses allowing to be
allowing to remain for an amortization period of 40 years and
We also mentioned that we were going to have meetings with the pyrite
Land owners for about the master plan, which brings me to the next slide
Which is what we heard from those landowners. We've over the last week and a half been talking to various landowners in the pyrite area about the master plan
And here's some of the things that we heard was concerned that there wasn't really a market for office or business park uses
the commercial
on the south side of SR 60 is more viable and
They didn't think it was a good idea to bring it to the other side of the freeway
There was concerns about the removal of the truck stop travel center use
particularly because they're one of the property owners has an application in process for a truck center and
There was also a discussion about possibly maybe changing how that use was
conceived to be more of a state-of-the-art
Carbon reduction center and talk about how that's where California regulations are headed and a suggestion that maybe there's some kind of public-private
benefit to that kind of a use
It was also concerned about the feasibility of the development of the industrial park until Riverside mining land really becomes available
This because they own kind of the center part of that industrial park
planning area and also
The continual use of the mines does have some impacts to surrounding uses with dust and noise
There was some concern with you know the compatibility of that mine mining use with the development of an industrial park
And then there was some mention about the consideration of doing a transitional overlay an opera an operating agreement for the existing uses and
Maybe there's some an opportunity to partner with the city here
They talked about improvements and intent enhancements to the
aesthetics of the existing uses that could happen right away
Potential of establishing new revenue streams for the city
And in an exchange to allows a phase out to the existing uses over the next 10 to 15 years and then transition over to the industrial park uses
Also
They felt it was more time that needed would be needed to confirm the legal status of the existing uses
You know, for example the pick-apart use and the in auto auction and then finally
Just an overall thought that additional time was needed to really work out a win-win solution with the property owners in the area
because overall they were in favor of the master plan but we're concerned with the current and
proposed uses and how that would really work with their their land
So the owners are requesting a 90-day no
Action period in order to kind of work with the the city to develop some of these concepts
so on just a quick
summary of our
Response to some of these issues
No market for office uses
No, I guess that we can really understand that with the COVID situation and certainly offices aren't as popular as they once were
But we like to point out that it's just one use
in the
List of land uses that would be allowed in the CT zone
So, you know, there's other options such as shops hotels entertainment restaurants and other
service uses
The commercial uses but also be centered around freeway exposure to travelers
So you have that kind of built-in market and dining and entertainment and lodging is certainly something that would be in demand along a freeway and
Also, just to note that, you know, the reason why we have lots of different uses in a particular zone is because the markets change over time
You know, and at some point in time, you know, office demand would come back. I know that, you know
Five years ago you wouldn't have on-demand office use and that's a popular thing that's happening now where people don't actually
own office buildings, but they have the opportunity to use office space when they need it and lease it out and
And then the comment about commercial more viable on the south side of the freeway
I think the shops of harupa actually demonstrate there's market demand for commercial uses along the freeway and
The proximity of the shops of harupa actually we see is a stimulus not a detriment to more commercial use along the area and
So that was our thoughts as far as the issue with no market for business park use
Right now we have a considerable amount of business park development going on in the city. So at least in harupa valley
We're not seeing that same trend
we have four projects under construction or in process total of 19 buildings and
Quite a bit of square footage being proposed. So there's there seems to be a market demand with these developers and
So we think that we do have the opportunity to develop business park in our community
and then finally and I think
the
the point brought up that we need more time and
To examine the proposed changes in the master plan area
Staff agrees with this concept
We think that recommend and we are recommending extending the review an approval timeline to consider and further discuss some of these issues
Such as the proposed transition or the existing uses
a potential short-term aesthetic improvements
Ways of generating revenue from the existing uses and then also we just need a little bit more time to look at the environmental review process
And what would be involved in that?
so
That's an overall summary of the third component and now I'd like to just kind of summarize and talk about the next steps
We look forward to getting in the comments from the community and the planning commission and city council tonight and your thoughts about
the project and the process and
We'll take that information and we'll complete the draft truck contents of use ordinance
we'll also finalize land use changes and
General plan amendments for initiation by the city council
will
also
Look at extending the moratorium
For the areas where we're making a land use changes or closing land changes
So we'd like some input on the city council's thought about that
further we'd like to
Have discussions with the property owners to complete the pyrite a north pyrite master plan and
Come up with a win-win solution for everybody there in a successful project
And then finally we'll be moving forward with public hearings and that brings me to the meeting dates our
first public hearing will be on
October 27th and that will be to discuss the truck intensive uses and in the initiation of the zone changes and
and then on
December 2nd assuming that the city council concurs to delay the north pyrite master plan
I should say and then on December 2nd
We would be considering with the city council truck intensive use ordinance and the initiation of the zone changes
Along with the possible extension of the moratorium or the locations
Under consideration of the zone changes only and then the other areas in the city would no longer be under the moratorium
and then finally the
We're looking at January and
For the north pyrite master plan to the planning commission in February of 2022 to the city council
So that ends my presentation. I know that it was a lot
Yeah, and you're probably tired of me talking. So I think I'll open that up to questions and comments. Thank you very much
Thank you, mr. Pessus
Bring it up to planning and council any questions for staff?
Mr. Birxin
Well, I would say first of all it's a whole lot to take in and you've covered our whole city
And and certainly fortunately, we're not here to make major decisions and we're not approving anything tonight
We're opening, you know the door for our community to take a look at this and
Provide feedback this will go to planning commission
I see the the calendar it shows, you know, basically one meeting for planning commission one for city council
But I can assure you if planning commission or council has
Questions which I can almost guarantee we all will it could push those dates
It's a super important issue, but I just want our residents to understand. We're not gonna rush this
We need to take the time to do it right a lot of interesting
Things have come out of this and you know, I look forward to seeing how this progresses
initial comments I have
Madam mayor
Yeah, I just wanted to say that I once again wanted to compliment staff on the quality of the report that they've given us
I think this is a lot to take in but it's very
well thought out and I
Think they've addressed a lot of the questions that we had and and just once again our staff is doing a really good job
Appreciate it. Thank you. Mm-hmm. Okay, so we have
About four speakers on this study session item. I will call John Chardlow first
You'll have three minutes
Thank you on our old council members planning commissioners. Thank you for these three minutes to
discuss the north pyrite master plan
our office represents
Property owners that have the picky part in the I a operations
I just also wanted to thank Jim and Joe for their for their time
I
Think that aerial is a great aerial showing the kind of riverside mining operations in between the two
other properties and until that property becomes
Usable
Really the the long-term vision plan can't you know operate and so you know in my perspective
The north pyrite master plan and the truck intensive uses purposes are completely contrary
What the city's long-term vision is actually to increase truck uses in that planning area be and while we think that is you know a potentially?
Vision that could be supported by everybody. It's just not valuable today
And so our concern or property owners concern is their properties rezoned and now there existing uses that are there today can't operate
And the property that the city wants the vision that the city wants to see there can't be there because of the mine and other
Environmental constraints obviously with a string fellow acid permit pits. There's some significant environmental constraints
Commissioner Newman, I'd love that opportunity to kind of talk with you about you know how that works
And so I think having that collective and cooperative conversation with
With city staff this week was extremely illuminating to us
And to them because I think there's there's a lot of complexities a lot of information
so I think having more time to
Collectively develop a plan is is great. And so we're supportive of that and
We just wanted to kind of re
State what we already stated and our we did submit a letter
But we support staff's recommendation and we think that additional time will be great
And we look forward to working with the city in the meantime. So thank you very much. Thank you for your comments
Jack Harold
Good evening commissioners council and staff appreciate the time tonight
I work with Crow Holdings, which is a family owned real estate development firm
We've been in the in the business for 70 years
Developed tens of millions of square feet of office retail
Hotel and industrial across the country and we've been active in the inland empire
You know we've been an escrow on a property in the north pyrite master plan area for over a year and have been anxiously awaiting the results of this study
and
We you know concur with staff's recommendations to push this out to further study
You know this this master plan update
anecdotally after you know
Reviewing the report internally with our product heads of office retail and industrial
You know, excuse me office retail and hotel
You know, they agreed that the market conditions for this foreseeable future
Would preclude them from developing what was recommended in the higher image zone?
You know, even prior to covid the demand for office, you know
Hotels and retail was weak at best and the pandemic has only accelerated those trends
And then you know I could sit up here and rattle figures off
But I thought it'd be more it resonated more with everyone if I gave two real world and real time examples of two projects that were working on the inland empire
the first of which is
In Ontario along the 10 it's about 10 acres of land where we're hoping to develop an office building and we've been in escrow for two years now
Marketing the the site, you know, tens of thousands of cars drive by that site every day. We've gotten zero bytes in the last two years
You know second example we're
About to break ground on 50 acres at the confluence of the 15 and 60 and a part of that entitlement process the city of Ontario
Asked us to do a retail study for a portion of the property
You know, we did multiple retail studies and unfortunately all of them, you know showed little demand for that area in retail
You know, I think those two areas are a little bit different, you know, probably a little bit higher image, but just food for thought
Again, thank you for the time and consideration tonight and thank you for the staff for the hard work on this
Thank you
Jim Kozak
Good evening council members and commissioners and staff. I first want to thank
City manager Butler and staff for really being transparent and opening up a dialogue with the landowners
That doesn't happen all the time in cities sometimes planners get off track and start planning things that
they get no input from
professionals that are in the business and
That has not been the case here. It's been very open and transparent and they've been very receptive
I'm here today to talk about
The North by right master plan. I represent
Echo investment partners and Lansing companies that owns
approximately 54 acres in that area that's got the image zone our
Our potential buyer crow holdings is is just spoke and
And I'm here to talk about the the concerns about the image center
I think in the initial design it sounds great to have dining
North of the 60 but the elephant in the room here is the spring phillocyte and with the intensive
concerns about people's health and the disclosures you have to make
other companies are going to just stay away from that so it I think it's it's
It's damaging to try to design something that in reality has
Never going to get developed because of some of the legacy issues that spring fellow brings to that area
So I'd like staff to really take another harder look about that and maybe get a little bit more realistic with types of uses
The other thing is I realize what a challenge it is in your position to represent all the residents of a group of Valley and
You know one council member that I
Worked with in another municipality told me you can never please a hundred percent of the people a hundred percent of the time
So it's a balancing act in juggling what's going to be the greater good
on certain issues and I think this master plan is representative of that because I
Don't know when many of you joined the council, but your goal was or if you had a vision
Like as an example, possibly I want to make a group of Valley the safest city in Riverside County
That's a great goal because
And maybe one of the reasons why the city incorporated
but
Sheriff's departments take 50 60 percent of the city's budget
So it's important if we're going to continue to try to improve
Services to the city that there's enough general fund money coming in and this unique property here has a great opportunity
To provide more economic revenue to the city
Without impacting residential communities because if it's on an off location off the pyrite interchange
So something to consider as we go forward in future discussions. Thank you. Thank you
Our final speaker on this is Tom Sears
Good evening members of the council members of the planning Commission staff
Okay, just one or two
My name is Tom Searles. I have been involved in
this area with a North pyrite
master plan area since 1999 and
First off, I would like to say take a little bit of time to complement
Commission Newman
Mission Newman you have forgotten
more about this area than I have learned over the last 20 years and the more I know the
more I know that
Your efforts over the last 40 years here have been
extraordinary not without challenges but extraordinary nonetheless I
Would welcome an opportunity
to
Take this time to really take this unique area
And I say unique because I've been developing industrial real estate in Southern, California
since 1978 my family's been
Developing since 1952 and my actually my family goes all the way back to 1870 here in this area. So
Been around this area for a long time
in general and I think this is a
extraordinary opportunity to do something
Really special
For a long time people were thinking
including the member the the state government up in Sacramento that kind of considered this is of a
terrible place
Because of the presence of string fellow asset pits
Through the efforts of Commissioner Newman and others including CCAHA and
Other activists and other people that cared
We're in a spot now we can actually have this conversation about something and
This could be this could be phenomenal I
Applause to ask recommendation to take a pause as a recommendation
To take the next 90 days to really explore this and do a deep dive in this thing and do it justice
So those are my comments
In common on the other activities regarding office. I've been developing office space since I was 23 years old
This is my IT department now, and this is a 10 year old computer, so I'm actually behind the times but
Things are changing and the way we conduct business
In the office environment
And I'd be more than happy to be able to share that
With staff council on the planning commission. Thank you
Thank you, mr. Serals. Okay, that was the last speaker
Mayor pro tem. Thank you mayor. I do want to command staff
This has been a almost year-long process where we kick this off and there's been a lot of work and a lot of discussions in the background
How does this gonna look how is that gonna look multiple resources looking at the different zoning and to take the
This clear this clean look at everything that is
industrial and heavy industrial across the city is no small feat and to have it done in with such precision and
Exactly with good recommendations on what we should do development standards rezoning generally on planned amendments all that stuff
And this time frame is astonishing
So I want to thank you guys. Thank you Joe. Thank you the entire team
in my opinion I
Like everything that's been presented. I think every use
The suggestions and recommendations. I'm fully in support of I
Like do like that you added that one thing where the land parcels that we're looking at
Changing because they no longer are used that maybe
Fits next to whoever it's at we continue that moratorium on those so we can
Change the zoning properly so we don't have that gap between zoning and moratorium ending where they try to submit plans that
We'll just come and create frustration for everybody and other ones that the ones that this potential ordinance would resolve
Those couldn't the moratorium can end because those have already got in the new development standards the new everything else
the
The pirate master plan. I am fully supportive what's there now, but I will go with the staff recommendation and
Continue working with the property owners and see if there's anything that that can be changed
negotiated compromised whatever
You know, the city has for years
been told you know, you'll never gonna get this you never again at this you're never gonna get this and
Recently we're trying to get everything that everyone 10 years ago told us we'd never get so we have heard that before
Well, I know many of you. I would recommend asking that you don't
Tell us because we've been told that and we are not building everything that we that everyone said when build here
With that I think that's all I have
again
the
Appreciate the work that's been done. This is
Amazing and I did here
I got the I saw the update on the stakeholder meeting and thank you to the residents who spoke Miss Anderson and everyone else
Thank you. I do appreciate all the comments. Um, I think this is a good compromise overall for land uses. So, thank you
Thank you mayor pro 10
Screw it. I also would like to commend the staff. This is an amazing presentation
I also want to quote one of our council members from a press enterprise
article back in 2017
When he said we all deserved to breathe clean air and not be bombarded by particulates. There's been a few
projects that have brought before us where
We kind of had let it slide
based on the fact that some of the residents would be supplied with
air filtration systems and my heart just breaks when that happens because then you're creating a situation
Where the people are forced to stay indoors and to go out in their backyard or to be outside?
Just limits their their mobility their enjoyment of the city
So whatever we can do that would reduce the diesel exhaust
And also the noise pollution
I'd like to see also
Evident emphasis put on the landscaping having particular landscaping which we've provided in
In the plan here that would remove or reduce the diesel particulates
I think also we should put an emphasis on adding more charging stations within the city for the electric vehicles and
One of one of my biggest pet peeves is the idling trucks
There's tremendous amount of diesel particulate going into the air with that
And I would like to also see a lot more in
regard to
anti idling
enforcement
getting getting our
Crews out there to check up on these various areas where the trucks are my understanding is a lot of the city's
City employees are doing
Checks on the different truck stops and issuing citations
But I also think that
This plan that we have going right now does cover a lot in regard to the truck intensive
Issues and I thank you for all your hard work and putting this together
Thank you, Commissioner Pruitt
Well, I also wanted to commend staff on all the hard word Jim Joe
This is an amazing presentation and also piggyback on Commissioner Pruitt about the emphasis on greenery and the landscaping charging station
Sound great and anti idling enforcement. That would be good if we could actually start working on something like that
And I do support the staff recommendation on extending this study, but and also the moratorium rate
That's also going to be extended
But well that it would come back and on the on the properties that would require additional work
Final Commission
Well, that's all my comment. Thank you, Madam Mayor. Thank you Councilwoman chair
Just a couple of things I see that we have that 500 foot
buffer area with residential and I just wanted to underscore that that's you know
It's not just a number we're picking that actually it's based on science and what science says is that the
Particulates and the health impacts reduce at to almost zero at 1,500 feet
Carb has set on a thousand feet which
Causes a diminishment of about 80 percent
So the 500 doesn't really help a lot
So, you know, let's not just settle on a number because it sounds well halfway there
I mean there's a reason behind that and I you know, I think the frustrations are there where we
continue to allow truck intensive
Uses and then we put in the air filters and the greenery and that really doesn't mitigate the problem
So the the real mitigation the real, you know, addressing the issue comes in the way that we're planning
So this I think is really a good a good plan at starting to address some of the areas where we have
truck storage like to the east of
The truck stop. I mean, there's massive trucks there along Riverside Avenue, which is no parking
We have trucks all the time and I know we keep going back to
Putting putting things in place and and hoping we can't enforce it
But I think all too often we aren't enforcing what we have and I think I had expressed to Joe before that
Our code enforcement needs to be beefed up or something or we need to rethink how we're trying we're assuming things are going to be
addressed
Because we get a lot of complaints from people about it. I think that area around pyrite. I'm glad there's a
Extension of time to discuss that. I think there's a lot of things to be talked about
At this point, I'm not real thrilled with warehousing being allowed up there
Mainly because people who live in that area have already been exposed to a hell of a lot and they don't need another type of
Exposure on top of that
But I'm open to talking about it and and having a discussion about it
It would be very helpful
I
Had a number of people talk to me today about the mess that is up there
along Granite Hill and the homeless and the garbage in you know
It's just quite unsightly so I guess anything would be an improvement
But we really need to think this through so I'm happy to participate in that
Any of my expertise comes because I'm getting older now and you accumulate stuff as you go through it
So I'm happy to add that into the mix for consideration
Thank you, Chair Newman
I would like to just say a great job to staff for the presentation and everything that's been presented
I'm okay with the extending extending the study in the future. I'm also okay with the
Recommendations on the pause for the north pyrite, you know
So we can get a little more insight on that
I would you just want to make sure that staff keeps in communication with the property owners that get affected make sure we have
Some kind of plan for them or we can work with them in the future
Maybe have someone especially designated for them to help them along if they're properties directly affected with the zone change or
Anything that happens with you
Obviously, I'm in agreeance with this plan and look forward to the next steps
It was a very thorough and complete staff report so kudos to the staff
Mr. Ferguson
Thank you, madam mayor
There's been a lot of focus at least by the
commenters tonight the
Pyrite area and that's an area extremely familiar to me
I've met with many property owners over the years in regards to what is gonna happen up there and
you know in council meetings in the past we've discussed things about that area and
With staff I've discussed things and you know the bottom line has always been I
Don't know what is going to be allowed up there because until we can get a better handle on
you know if if people are able to reside up there in the future or
If this is you know with the contaminants from string fell string fellow that that's really the key here is you know
how far out is that
impact what kind of businesses can be up there or
You know can it be a park could it not be a park?
Do we not want kids running around on top of this stuff?
You know there's all those questions now penny Newman is certainly the key here and we're very fortunate to have her
along for the ride and her input will be more valuable than certainly my input and so there's a huge reliance on her and
Her experience and knowledge of the area, but we really I agree
We need to take the time to figure out what would work best. I mean when that mine
Finishes up, you know the staff is correct. There's going to be a huge flat area
Well, that's not right on top of the string fellow area
So maybe there's something you know, we should be looking at ten years down the line. What's going to happen then?
We don't want to say this is the solution because this is the way the topography looks today
We need to consider what it's going to look like down the road and the same thing goes for the other item that we
The the bonus item bonus round item on Sierra, right?
By by the och Kory golf course
You know we we have a huge area steep topography hilly, but that doesn't mean
You know light agricultural. I'm not you know there that could be a variety of things of course
but
We should also be looking at things such as you know wind farm solar farm
other types of
Uses, you know, it's a high wind area first of all
So there's things to to consider
You know thinking a little outside the box as to all the possibilities
And so I just don't want to see us settle because this is what we were told is the only solution as we as as
Chris Barajas pointed out we have been told many times by many people. It's never going to happen
This isn't going to work. Well, you know, we're we're fighters here
The city has always fought for what we have and and what we desire and what our residents want and we'll continue that fight and
you know the
Point of this is simply let's look
Not just at what we have today, but what we also foresee down the road
the last thing I'll end it with this
Diesel particulates and semi trucks eventually aren't going to be an issue
Eventually they will all be electrified and that's happening quicker than you know it so a
Truck stop that we vision envision today
Which has fueling stations and those sorts of things bathrooms and showers and you know amenities
Eventually those are going to turn into charging ports and no more diesel fuel and we won't worry about or discuss idling because that just won't be a thing
so eventually we're going to get there so in the consideration of
What we're talking about we need to be cognizant that that is not a hundred years from now
That's a decade away two decades away
It's not that far and those things have to be also about in on this and staff's work planning Commission
You have a lot of work to do we have a lot of work to look at but certainly looking forward to to putting
Our place the way that our residents and we envision it and again
I know a commenter, you know
I think Jim Kozak that made the comment about you know, why did we run? Well, it was because we were unhappy with
County control
County controlling what went where and we are to this day trying to clean up the mess that was given to us
Not by choice, but by elected official who didn't even live in anywhere in our area at the time
None less now we have our own people
We we live here our families live here and we care about
Our areas, okay with that being said we'll go ahead and file this staff presentation
Thank you
And we will reconvene at seven good evening everyone and welcome to tonight's regular
City Council meeting this October 7th, 2021